il ya 50 ans l'abbé pierre lancé un
appel à la solidarité qui a marqué la
mémoire collective
l'hiver 54 avait révélé d'urgence de
porter secours aux plus démunis un demi
siècle a passé en france aujourd'hui il
y a près de trois millions sept cent
mille hommes et femmes qui vivent avec
moins de 600 euros par mois de ma place
du trocadéro la des pierres lancera à
plusieurs voix celle d'une dizaine
d'associations un nouvel appel contre
l'exclusion pour lutter contre
l'indifférence c'est le combat c'est
sans du fondateur du mouvement des
masses et indiquent elles parce qu'elles
car en janvier 54 paris gros lot par -15
degrés dans cette après guerre 29% des
français n'ont ni eau courante ni
électricité dans les faubourgs les
bidonvilles se multiplient le 7 janvier
le petit marc trois mois meurent de
froid dans les bras de sa mère le prêtre
député henri grouès de son nom de
résistant abbé-pierre appel à la
surrection de la bonté il faut que ce
soir même dans toutes les villes de
france
des pancartes s'accroche où l'on lise
c'est simplement toi qui souffrent qui
que tu sois entre dort mange reprend
espoir
ici on t'aime le succès de l'appel est
considérable la france généreuse se
mobilisent à courbevoie la première
opération récupération est un succès
meubles livres métaux sont collectés les
chiffonniers sonné mais il faut dépasser
l'urgence les emmaüs s'installe dans les
années 60 on construit au delà des
clivages politiques allant même hors des
frontières
l'abbé ses compagnons rassemble jusqu'à
faire des émules années 80 coluche et
les restes du coeur 90 le dal les
sans-logis la misère que l'on croyait
endiguer avec la croissance revient au
galop avec un autre visage puis complexe
plus sournois
c'est vrai que du point de vue du
logement on retrouve des similitudes
notamment auprès des jeunes notamment
pauvres et les populations immigrées qui
trouve pas qu'ils trouvent pas à se
loger
il ya ça il ya le fait que la précarité
et là on a une montée du chômage de
masse qu'on connaissait pas dans les
années 50 il suffisait de se baisser
pour retrouver de l'emploi alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est loin très
très loin d'être le cas depuis deux ans
l'abbé pierre a confié son bâton à
nouveau pèlerins martin hirsch
normalien neurobiologiste énarque
atypique le principal cadeau le seul
cadeau que le mouvement emmaüs peut
faire à son fondateur
c'est le lait dire que le combat
continue
mais tous les compagnons le savent avec
aujourd'hui trois millions sept cent
mille pauvres en france le combat n'est
pas gagné